now that President Biden's response to
the documents marked classified found at
his former office before his return from
a trip to Mexico Mr Biden said he was
quote surprised by the discovery and the
White House is fully cooperating with
the justice department review
republicans in Congress have launched
their own investigation Adriana Diaz
broke the story and she joins us with
the very latest Adriana good morning
good morning Vlad one question's
lawmakers want answered is how much Mr
Biden knew about the presence of the
roughly 10 documents and when CBS News
has learned the president was informed
on November 2nd the very day the
documents were discovered less than a
week before the midterm elections
people know I take classified documents
classifying information seriously in
Mexico Tuesday President Biden said he
was surprised to learn classified
government records were discovered in
November at a private office he used
after his vice presidency but I don't
know what's in the documents I've turned
over the boxes they've turned over the
boxes to the archives and we're
cooperating fully cooperating fully with
the review and which I hope will be
finished soon a source tells CBS News Mr
Biden was informed the day the documents
were discovered another source tells us
the documents which were found inside a
box in a locked closet had multiple
levels of classification and included
highly classified material the
republican-led house oversight committee
has announced it is launching an
investigation and asked the White House
for all documents retrieved from
President Biden's personal office and a
list of who had access to that office
this happened November 2nd Joe Biden
said he would be the most transparent
president in American history why are we
just now learning this the inquiry is
drawing comparisons to the investigation
into former president Trump's handling
of classified documents in that case
more than 300 were recovered from
Mar-A-Lago last year after Trump
resisted multiple requests to turn them
over Trump Tuesday questioned the lack
of disclosure posting why didn't the
justice department announce the highly
classified documents found in the Biden
office before the election Democrats
pushed back against any wrongdoing by Mr
Biden show the discovery of President
Biden's classified documents been
disclosed before the midterms what
President Biden did was disclose this to
the archives
let law enforcement know that is exactly
the way that you should handle this
a source tells CBS News the Justice
Department's review led by U.S attorney
John lausch a trump appointee is largely
done Republicans are asking top
intelligence officials for a damage
assessment Gail
all right Adriana thank you very much